[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم هدد الرئيس اليمني عبد الربو
منصور هادي بكشف ما وصفها ملفات الفساد
المرتبطه بالنظام السابق جاء ذلك ردا على
اعتراض حزب المؤتمر الشعبي على قرار
بالغاء استجوابات قدمها في مجلس النواب ضد
حكومه الوفاق الوطني نتوقف مع هذا الخبر
لنناقش من
زاويتين دوافع اطلاق الرئيس اليمني لهذا
التهديد وطبيعه ملفات الفساد التي لوح
بكشفها والى اي مد بات حزب المؤتمر الشعبي
عبءا على عمليه التحول السياسي في
اليمن
في اجتماع استثنائي مع اعضاء مجلس مجلسي
النواب والوزراء اطلق الرئيس اليمني منصور
هادي تهديده بكشف ملفات فساد النظام
السابق مؤكدا ان اغلبيه اليمنيين يؤيدون
التغيير وان المعترضين عليههم هم اما
اصحاب مصالح او فاسدين او تجار سلاح على
حد تعبيره ياتي هذا فيما تشير مصادر يمنيه
الى ان العمليه السياسيه باتت على صفيح
ساخن في ظل توتر العلاقه بين الرئيس هادي
وحزب المؤتمر الشعبي بزعامه الرئيس
المخلوع علي عبد الله صالح وذلك بعد
الافراج عن المعتقلين المتهمين في تفجيرات
دار الرئاسه قبل
عامين بمشقه واضحه يحاول اليمن رسم ملامحه
الجديده وفي توافق نادر لن تجد يمنيين
يختلفان على ان البلاد تواجه تحديات
سياسيه وامنيه واقتصاديه
وانسانيه قبل نحو 20 شهرا اطلقت العمليه
الانتقاليه في اليمن واليوم لا تزال في
عجلاتها عصي كثيره تعمقت الخلافات
الايديولوجيه والقبليه والانتماءات
الحزبيه الى حد بدا فيه عقد مؤتمر حوار
وطني شامل نجاحا في حد ذاته يحدث ذلك
بينما برلمان البلد في ازمه حاده منذ
انسحبت كتله احزاب اللقاء المشترك التي
ناصرت ثوره الشباب السلميه من جلساته
حجتها في ذلك مخالفه رئاسه البرلمان وكتله
حزب المؤتمر الشعبي العام الذي يراسه
الرئيس اليمني المخلوع بنود المبادره
الخليجيه يخشى ان تنسف ازمه البرلمان
التسويه السياسيه القائمه في البلاد اذا
امتدت الى الحكومه ومن الاحتمالات
المطروحه ايضا ان يتدخل الرئيس عبد ربو
منصور هادي لحل البرلمان وانشاء هيئه
تشريعيه جديده لما تبقى من الفتره
الانتقاليه طالب جميع الكتل بالعوده
لجلسات البرلمان على اساس التوافق الذي
حددته المبادره الخليجيه ومع ذلك فانه لا
يزال يرى قوا تحاول جر اليمن الى الخلف
تحدث عن قله من اصحاب المصالح او الفاسدين
او تجار السلاح تعارض التغيير كما وهدد
بكشف ما وصفها بملفات الفساد المرتبطه
بالنظام
السابق الرجل الذي كان يوما نائبا لعبد
الله صالح لم يحدد طبيعه الملفات ولم يقل
لما سكت عنها حتى الان لكن تهديداته تسلط
الضوء من جديد على طبيعه علاقته بحزب
المؤتمر الشعبي الذي اصبح براي معارضيه
عقبه في طريق التحول السياسي في اليمن
بانتظار اتضاح الصوره يجدد هادي دعوته
للقوى السياسيه كافه الى تغليب مصلحه
الوطن قالها امام المبعوث الدولي جمال بن
عمر الذي بد له ان اليمن انجز شوطا كبيرا
في تنفيذ العمليه
الانتقاليه معنا في هذه الحلقه من صنعاء
كل من الدكتور عادل الشرجبي استاذ علم
الاجتماع السياسي في جامعه صنعاء ومحمد
العمراني الناشط في الثوره الشبابيه
اليمنيه اهلا بضيفي نبدا بالدكتور الشرجبي
ما الذي دكتور دفع الرئيس اليمني الى
التهديد بكشف ملفات الفساد في العهد
السابق
الذي دفعه الى يعني التهديد بكشف ملفات
الفساد هو الاسلوب الذي تسير به العمليه
السياسيه في اليمن والاسلوب الذي تسير به
اجهزه الدوله ومؤسساتها وهو اسلوب شخصي
وا يعني العمليه السياسيه هناك اطراف لم
تستوعب مضامين المبادره الخليجيه واليتها
التنفيذيه التي ينبغي ان تقوم على التوافق
ولا زالت تقوم يعني تدعي انها لازالت
تتمتع بالشرعيه الانتخابيه رغم ان الشرعيه
الانتخابيه قد سقطت وفقا للمبادره
الخليجيه ومطالب الشعب قبل ذلك قبل
المبادله الخليجيه ان الشعب خرج في ثوره
هي استفتاء على
ا المؤسسات القائمه وعلى الدستور القائم
وعلى النظام بشكل عام وان هذا الشعب يريد
التغيير الا ان هناك قله ربما حددها
الرئيس عبد الربى منصور هادي ب 15% عندما
قال ان 85% من الشعب يريد التغيير وان
هناك فقط اقليه هي التي تقاوم التغيير
اعتقد ان هذه الاقليه لم تستوعب ما الذي
كيف ينبغي ان تدار العمليه الانتقاليه
وانها لازالت تريد ان تدير الدوله بنفس
اساليبها السابقه اعتقد ان هناك ارادتين
حاليا اراده للتغيير واراده تريد ان تبقي
على النظام السابق عبد ربا منصور هادي
واقع بين هاتين الارادتين وقد فوضته
المبادره الخليجيه مساله التوفيق في
الاراء بين كل التوجهات سواء في البرلمان
او في الحكومه او في غيرها المؤسسات ولكن
اسمح لي اسمح لي دكتور اسمح لي دكتور
التهديد بفتح ملفات الفساد وهنا اسمح لي
انقل السؤال للسيد العمراني التهديد بفتح
ملفات الفساد الا يعتبر ارباك للصفقه
المتكامله للمبادره الخليجيه وهي ترتيب
وضع سياسي جديد للبلاد مع
اغلاق قوس العهد
السابق اعتقد دعني بالبدايه اعلق على على
على
على الموضوع برمت نحن نعتقد ان بقاء
المخلوع علي عبد الله صالح في قمه حزب
سياسي قامت ضده ثوره او قامت ضد هذا الرجل
ثوره شعبيه وشبابيه كامله اجتثت ورمته
خارج
الاسوار نحن حتى الان لم نفهم بالضبط كيف
كيف تستوعب المبادره الخليجيه مثل هذا
التصرف تفضل تفضل ولو انه موضوع موضوع حزب
المؤتمر الشعبي تحديدا سن تناوله ك كزا
زاويه منفصله زاويه منفصله في في لو لو
تكرمت يعني فقط انهي الجمله
يعني موضوع الحزب الحاكم سابقا سيكون
موضوعنا بعد الفاصل اردت الان فقط ان
نتحدث عن هذا التلويح بفتح ملفات الفساد
لو تكرمت الا يعتبر ارباك للمبادره
الخليجيه لا اعتقد بل بل بالعكس المبادره
الخليجيه علي الرئيس هادي يفهم تماما ان
الرئيس المخلوع علي عبد الله صالح لا يفهم
الا لغه التهديدات
ونلاحظ نحن من بدايه مشواره وفي بدايه
المبادره الخليجيه واصلا كان يستجيب
لتهديدات مجلس الامن وكان يستجيب لتهديدات
الامم المتحده ولم يتفهم دائما الاستجابات
الشعبيه والضغط الشعبي ولذلك ياتي هذا
التهديد في توقيته المناسب في اعتقادي
لانه هذا الرجل لا يفهم الا لغه التهديدات
ولا يفهم الا
لغه القوه لغه ال لغه فضح كشف ملفات
الفساد امام العالم حتى يتعرف الناس على
حقيقه علي عبد الله صالح وعلى حقيقه لماذا
قامت الثوره اليمنيه ولماذا قام شباب
الثوره اليمنيه باسقاط هذا الرجل ولذلك
نحن لا نعتقد ان يعني ا اقصد اقصد الحديث
عن فتح ملفات الفساد التي ستطال حتما
الرئيس السابق يعني ان الحصانه التي قيل
انها لعلي عبد الله صالح لن تصبح قائمه
هذا ما
قصدته
الحصانه يتنكر لها علي عبد الله صالح لانه
يبقى يمارس العمل السياسي يبقى يبقى يثير
الفوضى هذا الرجل هو عباره عن مصنع
الازمات والمشاكل ولذلك هذا الرجل هو الذي
يتنكر للعمليه السياسيه ويقود حزب المؤتمر
الشعبي العام في هذا
الاتجاه هناك ايضا ملاحظه اخرى دكتور
شرشبي
التهديد بشيء عمليا يصعب تحقيقه وهو فتح
كل ملفات الفساد في العهد السابق الا يحول
ضروره مكافحه الفساد الى ورقه ضغط في
مساومات سياسيه داخليه اكثر منها توجه جاد
ل فتح هذا الملف بشكل
حقيقي نعم قد يكون ذلك لكن اذا ما اخذنا
بعين الاعتبار طبيعه النخبه السياسيه
وبالذات البرلمان لانه كان حديثه هو
بمناسبه او في جلسه لعقد مصالحه بين
الحكومه والبرلمان لان هناك اختلافات منذ
على الاقل ثلاثه اشهر بين الحكومه
والبرلمان
وطبيعه النخبه المسيطره على البرلمان هي
من النخب التقليديه التي لا تهمها الا
المصالح الشخصيه فعندما تتضرر مصالحها
الشخصيه المباشره الماديه فانها بذلك
تستجيب لبعض الطلبات لانها لا تستوعب
قضايا المصلحه الوطنيه ولا تتخوف من حروب
اهليه ولا تتخوف من شيء
ف عمد الرئيس عبد الربو منصور هادي الى
اللعب على هذا الوتر انه يحاول ان يخيفها
بمصالح شخصيه طويله لها منذ فتره طويله
وبالتاكيد عندما
يقصد القضايا الفساد هو لا يقصد قضايا
الفساد السابقه ولكن منذ تم التوقيع على
المبادره الخليجيه لان المبادره الخليجيه
لا تعطي الحصانه على ما بعدها ولكنها تعطي
للفتره السابقه عليها هناك قضايا فساد
كبيره مارستها هذه النخب بعد التوقيع على
المبادره الخليجيه وينبغي ان تحاسب عليها
وبالتالي فالرئيس عبد الربو منصور هادي
يعلم ان هذه النخب عندما يهددها بشكل شخصي
وهذا من تجربه الفتره الانتقاليه منذ
بدايتها كان الرئيس السابق والمؤتمر
الشعبي العام لا يستجيبون لمطالب الرئيس
ها ولمتطلبات العمليه الانتقاليه الا
عندما يهددهم مجلس الامن او اي مؤسسه
داخليه او اقليميه او دوليه بمصالحهم
الشخصيه كفرض عقوبات او ما الى ذلك
فبالتالي اعتقد ان عبد الرب منصور هادي
استفاد من هذه القضيه فبالتالي بدا يخيف
هذه النخب على على الرغم من التعقيدات
التي تحدثت عنها وان امكانيه تطبيق ذلك
بشكل بنيوي على كل مؤسسات الدوله قد يكون
امرا صعبا ولكن سوف تتم المساله بشكل
اختياري للافراد الذين يعرقلون الانتقال
السلمي للسلطه ويعرقلون المسيره السياسيه
وهؤلاء معدودين كما اشار الرئيس عبد الربا
منصور هادي نعم هذا هذه الاخافه للنخبه
سيد العمراني يمكن ان تعطي
نتيجه ن نعتقد انها ستعطي نتيجه لانهم
هؤلاء لهم ملفات فساد كبيره جدا حتى الان
لا يعلم عنها الشعب شيئا حتى الان بالرغم
من كل ما قيل عن الفساد بالرغم من كل
ملفات الفساد التي فتحت الا ان الملفات
التي فتحت لا تعبر عن الفساد الحقيقي الذي
كان موجود في اجهزه الدوله والذي كان
تديره هذه هذه العصابه ولكن ولكن طالما ان
الرئيس عبد الربو منصور هذه لوح بذلك من
باب التهديد والضغط اكثر منها الا يخشى ان
يؤثر ذلك
على مصداقيه محاربه الفساد حتى وان حصل
ذلك في مرحله
مقبله لا لا اعتقد ذلك لا اعتقد لانه
ا محاربه الفساد لها اجهزتها الرسميه
الموجوده داخل البلد والذي كان ايضا
الرئيس السابق المخلوع علي عبد الله صالح
يحاول الاستفاده منها من خلال تبني لجنه
تبني هيئه مكافحه الفساد التي ينتخبها
مجلس الشورى الذي يحضر فيه المخلوع بصفه
الاغلبيه بحكم ان هؤلاء الناس عينهم
الرئيس المخلوع علي عبد الله صالح بصفه
شخصيه بمعرفته الشخصيه ملفات الفساد من
الاشياء المهمه التي سيهتم بها علي عبد
الله صالح المخلوع علي عبد الله صالح
ونعتقد انها ستعطي نتيجه ايجابيه وسفا
معها الشعب بشكل اكبر ولكن هل هل ملفات
الفساد دكتور الشرجبي هل ملفات الفساد
مرتبطه فقط بالنخب الس السياسيه الحاكمه
السابقه دون غيرها في
اليمن طبعا اذا اخذنا الفساد الكبير فهو
كان مرتبط بالنخب السياسيه الحاكمه واذا
اخذنا الفساد بمفهومه العام فبالتاكيد
هناك فساد على المستوى الموظف الصغير وعلى
المستوى الاجتماعي وهؤلاء ينتمون الى فئات
وشرائح اجتماعيه مختلفه والى مكونات
سياسيه مختلفه فبالتالي هو يقصد الفساد
الكبير طبعا نحن اذا اخذنا جذور هذه
الاشكال هي بدات عندما بدا الاختلاف بين
مجلس النواب والحكومه حول قانون الجامعات
اليمنيه قوه التغيير تريد ان يتم انتخاب
رؤساء الجامعات اليمنيه والقيادات
الاكاديميه انتخابا من قبل هيئات التدريس
فيما الحزب الحاكم لازال يريد ان يظل
الاسلوب القديم اللي هو التعيين من قبل
رئيس الدوله وهذ هو يعني تم فيها عمليات
فساد كبيره مالي واداري وحتى يعني يعني
اخلاقي معظم رؤساء الجامعات الذين عينوا
في عهد علي عبد الله صالح لا تنطبق عليهم
الشروط الاكاديميه المنصوص عليها حتى في
القانون القديم فبالتالي عبد ربا منصور
هادي يقول اما ان يتم التغيير وعفى الله
عما سلف او اننا حتى نحاسبهم بالقوانين
القديمه فهناك من التشريعات ما يمكن ان
نستخدمها في محاسبتهم على ملفات فساد ليس
فقط قديمه قبل توقيع المبادره الخليجيه
ولكن ايضا حتى بعد بعد توقيع المبادره
الخليجيه هناك ملفات فساد كبيره تصور ان
الحكومه
اليمنيه تسند لشيخ قبلي او هناك
مقبره مكونه من 50 لبنه بالمفهوم اليمني
اعطت احد المشايخ 30 لبنه من اجل ان يقوم
بحمايه ال 20 اللبنه الباقيه يعني هناك
اشكال من الفساد لا يصدقها العقل تختلف عن
كل اشكال الفساد في العالم فبالتالي
الرئيس عبد الربى منصور هادي بيده كثير من
الملفات من ملفات الفساد التي يستطيع فعلا
بها ان يحاسب اي مسؤول لكنه يح ربما ربما
المفارقه دكتور ربما هنا المفارقه بان
الرئيس اليمني هو نائب رئيس حزب المؤتمر
الشعبي الذي ما زال يراسه الى الان علي
عبد الله صالح فبالتالي هناك بعض الالتباس
في هذا الحديث عن حزب حاكم سابق في علاقته
الان بالمشهد السياسي الجدي في اليمن لنا
عوده لموضوع حزب المؤتمر الشعبي والى اي
مدى يمكن ان يربك ما يجري الان في اليمن
لنا عوده بعد قليل نرجو ان تبقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها ابعاد تهديد
الرئيس اليمني عبد الربو منصور هادي بكشف
ما وصفها بملفات الفساد المرتبطه بالنظام
السابق سيد العمراني فيما يتعلق بحزب
المؤتمر الشعبي الذي اشرت اليه قبل قليل
وقلت بان بانك لم تهضم بعد ان يكون الرئيس
السابق مازال على راسه ويلعب دورا في
الحياه السياسيه هل تعتقد الان بان هذا
الداء الذي اشرت اليه بين قوسين هو الان
الذي افسد ربما او اربك على الاقل عمليه
التحول الديمقراطي في
اليمن نعم لو تلاحظ ان شباب الثوره من
اللحظه الاولى لم يطالبوا مثلا باسقاط حزب
المؤتمر الشعبي العام ولم يتبنوا قانون
لقانون العزل فيما يتعلق بقياده المؤتمر
الشعبي العام او فيما يتعلق بالمؤتمر
الشعبي العام كان هدفهم من البدايه اسقاط
نظام علي عبد الله صالح لانهم يعلمون ان
نظام علي عبد الله صالح وعائله علي عبد
الله صالح هي الداء المستطير ا ونحن حتى
الان نستغرب ان حزب المؤتمر لم يلتقط هذه
المبادره الشبابيه الغير مكتوبه بالهجوم
على المؤتمر الشعبي العام مثل ما حصل في
تونس ومثل ما حصل في مصر من قوانين للعازل
ومن ومن غيرها ا المؤتمر الى الان الى
الان هناك صراع حقيقي داخل المؤتمر بين
قوى تريد جر المؤتمر الشعبي العام الى
مربع التغيير والمشروع الوطني وهناك قوى
مرتبطه بنظام علي عبد الله صالح ومرتبطه
بجماعه علي عبد الله صالح وبعاده علي عبد
الله صالح
تحاول اضفاء لغه الشرعيه على علي عبد الله
صالح وعودته لان المؤتمر الشعبيه العام هو
البوابه الحقيقيه الوحيده التي يمكن ان
تعود بعلي عبد الله صالح وهذا واضح فعلا
حقيقه من خلال تبني بعض القنوات الاعلاميه
لعوده علي عبد الله صالح الى الواجهه ونحن
كشباب ثوره نستغرب من هذه التصرفات ا و
ونستغرب ايضا ان الدول الراعيه للمبادره
الخليجيه التي رفضها شباب الثوره من
البدايه ان لا تنتبه لمثل هذه التصرفات
التي تحاول ان تعيد ان تعيد مربع الثوره
الى المنتصف ا شباب الثوره الان ربما
يستعدون للنزول الى الميدان لمقاومه مثل
هذه التغييرات في حاله انه الثوره ستخرج
من مساراتها او او المشروع الوطني سيخرج
من مساراته نحن نعتقد ان علي عبد الله
صالح وجود علي عبد الله صالح على راس حزب
المؤتمر الشعبي العام لم يعد شانا داخليا
يخص المؤتمر الشعبي العام وانما اصبح شانا
يمنيا بامتياز لانه مرتبط بالمبادره
الخارجيه ومرتبط بالمسار التسويه السياسيه
ومرتبط بالمسار السياسي على حد على حد
سواء ومشروع الوطني علي عبد الله صالح لا
يمكن ان يندمج ضمن المشروع الوطني نهائيا
لان هذا الرجل قامت ضده ثوره باعتباره
فاسدا باعتباره
ا ظالما باعتباره لا يمتلك مشروع سياسي
حقيقي للبلد قامت ثور فنحن نستغرب حقيقه
الان نعم اسمح لي حتى على افتراض اللي
نقول بان الرئيس السابق ابتعد عن رئاسه
الحزب وهنا اسال الدكتور عادل الشرجبي هل
القضيه اعمق من ان من مجرد انه علي عبد
الله صالح هو رئيس المؤتمر لان هناك حزب
حكم لسنوات وبالتالي به لوبيات وبه مصالح
مرتبطه بالرئيس السابق ولكنها قد تتحرك
حتى
بدونه نعم نعم طبعا نحن اذا نظرنا للمؤتمر
الشعبي العام فهو يشكل دوله موازيه للدوله
في اليمن كان وليس مجرد حزب حاكم في دوله
ديمقراطيه هو حزب عائلي يمثل
جهاز دوله موازي لجهاز الدوله الرسمي
وبالتالي يختلف الامر عن بقيه الدول
العربيه حتى اكثرها فسادا التي تسيرها
دوله عميقه نحن لدينا دوله موازيه
وبالتالي ف اذا لم تكن هناك اجراءات حاسمه
من قبل عبد رب منصور هادي ومن قبل رعاه
المبادره الخليجيه ومن قبل شباب الثوره
ومن قبال قوه والتغيير باتجاه تحجيم دور
علي عبد الله صالح السياسي واللوبي
المرتبط به فان علي عبد الله صالح حتى لو
ابعد من رئاسه المؤتمر الشعبي العام سوف
يظل مؤثرا لانه لو لاحظنا في خطاب عبد رب
منصور هادي اليوم اما في هذا الاجتماع
الاستثنائي للاحظنا بانه يتحدث حول كيف
تسير بعض مؤسسات الدوله عبر اتصالات
هاتفيه ف مثلا البرلمان رئيس البرلمان
يعني مرتبط ارتباط مباشر بالرئيس السابق
علي عبد الله صالح ولا يتخذ اي خطوه الا
بالتنسيق معه وكانه ليس رئيسا لبرلمان
للجمهوريه اليمنيه وانما هو رئيس لهيئه
تتبع علي عبد الله صالح بشكل شخصي
وبالتالي فانا اقول فعلا سيظل علي عبد
الله صالح مؤثرا لكن سوف يتراجع ا مدى هذا
التاثير وبالتالي مطلوب الى جانب ابعاده
المؤتمر الشعبي العام اتخاذ اجراءات تبعده
عن المجال السياسي وليس فقط عن المؤتمر
الشعبي العام لان من اعدوا المبادره
الخليجيه ليست لديهم رؤيه متعمقه في طبيعه
الدوله اليمنيه وبنيتها السياسيه وطبيعه
التشريعات التي تحكم المؤسسات وطبيعه
العلاقه قد يكون يعني اسمح لي اسمح لي قد
يكون من بين الاجراءات و ما اتخذه مثلا
مؤخرا او ما قيل ان الرئيس عبد المصور
هادي اتخذها وهو تجميد اموال الحزب هل اذا
ما تاكد ذلك هل هي بدايه محاوله تحجيم
التاثير الحقيقي لهذا
الحزب طبعا هذه مساله مهمه جدا في السياسه
اليمنيه لانه المؤتمر الشعبي العام حزب لا
يمتلك شعبيه في الشارع هو يعتمد
على يعني شراى ولاء بعض ولاءات بعض النخب
ويعتمد على النخب التق ليه المؤثره كشيوخ
القبائل وكال الشخصيات الدينيه وبعض
المثقفين المؤثرين وي يسير علاقته
بالجماهير عبر اسلوب يمكن تسميته باسلوب
ملكه النحل هو يصطاد الملكه والخليه كلها
تتحرك وراء هذا الشخص ولكن اسمحلي حب نعم
اسمح لي مره اخرى حزب المؤتمر وهنا اسال
السيد العمراني حزب المؤتمر الشعبي يبدو
ايضا انه ليس مستسلم لقدره الجديد هو قادر
على على التاثير هناك حديث عن ان
ربما هناك نوع من التحالف بينه وبين
الحوثيين
في جلسات الحوار الوطني هناك حديث عن ان
ربما
ايضا حزب الاصلاح ربما ايضا بتاثيره في
العمليه السياسيه ربما يجعل حزب المؤتمر
الشعبي ايضا لديه بعض الملاحظات الوجيه ما
رايك في هذه
الاراء نحن اعتقد ان حزب المؤتمر الشعبي
العام حزب المعتمر الشعبي العام حتى ولو
تحالف مع الحوثيين بالنهايه نحن لدينا
مشروع وطني يجب ان ينفذ وهذا المشروع
الوطني سنسان وهناك 90% من الشعب الامني
شباب الثوره مع 90% من الشعب الامني
يساندون مشروع التغيير والمشروع
الوطني ولا يمكن لقوى حتى مهما امتلكت من
القوى ان تعيق هذا المشروع مهما امتلكت من
اساليب القوى والضغط ان تعيق هذا المشروع
لا يمكن ل ونحن نطالب الرئيس هذ ان لا
يستسلم حقيقه لمشروع الضغوط لانه هناك
ضغوط حقيقيه وكبيره تمارس على الرئيس هادي
وابتزاز من ضمن من ضمنها مثلا تعيينات
الاخيره التي اجريت قبل قبل فتره والتي
خرج الشباب اليمني وخرج كثير من ابناء من
ابناء منطقه اب ضد هذه القرارات هي عباره
عن محاوله لزج الرئيس هادي في مواجهه مع
الشعب او في مواجهه مع شباب الثوره على
وجه الخصوص ولهذا نحن نعتقد نحن نعتقد ان
على الرئيس هادي ان يثق بالمشروع الوطني
وان ينطلق معتمدا على الشباب اليمني وعلى
الار اليمنيه لانها ستنكسر امامها كل
الارادات نحن نعتقد اننا اقوى من كل هذ هل
تعتقد سيده عمران بان الرئيس عبد الربو
منصور هادي قد يخرج من عباءه هذا الحزب
وبالتالي يتخلص من مسؤوليه معينه ويصبح
قادر على اداره اللعبه السياسيه بشكل
افضل انا شخصيا اتمنى ان يفعل الرئيس هادي
ذلك لان حزب المؤتمر الشعبي العام سيتحول
حينها الى حزب خاص بعلي عبد الله صالح حزب
خاص بالعائله ولعل الرئيس هادي كان يحاول
خلال كل هذه الفتره السابقه ان يخرج بهذا
الحزب من هذا الاطار او من هذه الدائره
المغلقه شكرا جزيلا لك محمد العمراني
الناشط في الثوره الشبابيه اليمنيه شكرا
ايضا لضيفنا الدكتور عادل الشرجبي استاذ
علم الاجتماع السياسي في جماعه صنعاء
وبهذا مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد وصلنا الى
نهايه هذه الحلقه كالعاده نذكركم بان
بامكانكم متابعه حلقات هذا البرنامج على
موقع الجزيره نت بالتفصيل وعبر يوتيوب
ايضا يمكنكم مشاهده اعاده لهذه الحلقه
دمتم في رعايه الله والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء